[Applause]
[Music]
most people don't realize that we're
losing a generation to violence kids in
this area are in danger every day even
one in school I mean literally thousands
of being shot every year hundreds dying
from gun violence is senseless you can
look in their eyes and see hopelessness
they don't believe they're gonna live to
see 21 25 so they don't plan for a
future so violence is cool because in
their mind they're gonna be gone anyway
I realized they need somebody in the
community besides gay that believes in
them
[Music]
my mom brought me in to Chicago when I
was two weeks old and we've been here
ever since
eight kids 15 grandkids I have my family
all around me 15 years ago my daughter
Aisha was 13 she had nine friends girls
and boys and I saw I'm running up and
down the street and I was like what they
gonna do next
they're young people they need the stuff
to keep them occupied so when they're
out in the community and they're around
the kids that are in gangs well then
they got the next thing I knew they were
at that stage and I wanted to give them
a safe place away from all that so I had
epiphany I went out there and I brought
him into my house they told me in those
first few hours you know I'm telling
this school I need help or my dad's
gonna my mom's on drugs you know I'm
like I'm in shock if I'm there I just
started getting involved I start sitting
with them and listening in the next
couple of days they were kids started
knocking on my door that I didn't know
and they were saying you missed Diane
and I'm like yeah and yeah so I so said
you can help me I want to go back to
school and then the next day there were
five and six and then they were saying I
want to get out of the gang and then
homeless kids were at my door late at
night and I honestly didn't know what I
was doing I just wanted to do it you
weren't trying to find a job what you
shine this
I might get a job any time well I want
you having the one u18 that right so
this time I was worried about you there
for a minute
cuz there was too much going on seemed
like he was angry about it too but you
good now yeah
so this is 119 Street one of the most
violent areas well I'd say the most
violent area in our community
at first they make you wonder what like
nothing's gonna change just get out just
go do something else and then you go if
we leave then what I mean I can't do
everything but I can do that I can do
when you live on a block with ten houses
and there's five or six who have lost
people to gun violence
then it affects the whole the whole
neighborhood and so what I really wanted
to help
[Music]
kids off the block KOB is an
organization unto itself during school
months we provide after-school
programming which consists of the
tutoring and the mentoring and workshops
and then in the summer months
violence eats up a lot I thought need
and there was a vacant lot across the
street so I turned it into a basketball
court when the kids are playing
basketball nothing else matters
and that is the truth it's a powerful
thing it literally brings boys together
1 different gangs run different cliques
they play on the court together or they
eat together or they laugh together so
that's what it's there for
we estimated that over 3,000 young
people have been impacted will come
through the program
it became so many reasons to come to
Kelby instead of the game so we became a
force
[Music]
when I hear that someone's been shot or
killed it drains you I wanted to do
something that was shocked my community
let the young people see they're losing
their friends to violence and that's how
the memorial started those young people
on those stones somebody loved them they
belonged to people they're just not
names they were actually living life and
they're gone it makes you think how
fragile life is for all of us
[Music]
there are 791 stone and we still have
421 names there every one of them over
there I was 24 years old I've seen two
gang members literally come to the
memorial and go out and get a job and go
back to school seriously the next day
today we're expanding we actually have a
space next door in the building and we
can get out of my house the spaces are
ready yet but I know what it's going to
look like so I'm excited here will be
our computer lab computers and Printers
desk here will be a music studio right
in the middle and over there on the side
would be our clothing design program
they need lifetime career skills and for
us to be able to give them that would
take the power of the violence the guns
the gangs all of that out cuz I ain't
brought peace to the neighborhood I used
to go I can't oh all the time probably
wouldn't like game it's a games and
stuff but
as I am told me just to be myself be a
leader not a follower if it wasn't for
my Smith I am I honestly wouldn't know
why I be
cuz I've been through a lot she always
been there for me I have done a lot for
this community from feeding to clothes
into housing cementery me myself I call
her the Big Mama this generation what
you're doing makes a difference in the
community and each and every mother who
lost their child she doesn't back off
and give in easy
if she has an idea she'll stop at
nothing that make it happen in fact
that's what she does
[Music]
they were gone rough now I approach to
start kids out blah see always looking
out
[Music]
I don't think a kid should have to be
worried that they can't walk their own
stream a kid should be worried about is
bubble gum wrapper a seventeen-year-old
could worried about prom graduating
african-american youth are not the enemy
and these people like myself who out
here while fighting every day to change
that perception and we're gonna do it
and we might not have big money
corporations and all that but never
doubt people like us because we'll find
a way because we live it stop judging
how our young people give them the same
opportunities that everybody else can
cuz I I guarantee you you'll find some
genius just give them the opportunity my
goal is for kids off the block to be in
every city in this nation and we're
working on them I've been doing this for
15 years
and I'm not stop
[Music]
you
you